all right old man let's see what you got
so the first trailer has hit for Logan
the final film in which Hugh Jackman
will appear as Logan also known as The
Wolverine also known as James hallett
but nobody cares about that name this is
the last time he's playing the part it's
going to be rated R it's coming out next
year we've had some stills we've got a
little bit information our first real
look at it what do I think well they're
committing to it I'll give them that I
think the choice of the Johnny Cash song
was kind of an obvious one but i like
the general vibe that it granted me he
was a small touch that i actually really
like about the use that song what I
would have expected is for them is the
fade island for us to get more generic
sort of action etrailer music and once
the actual sort of action beat it but
they didn't they stuck with the music
all the way through my pay yeah that
works for me I like that better cuz then
it feels less like maybe they're trying
to trick us into a vibe with the music
and it could still fit even this thing's
got action II as far as what we see i
like how beaten down Logan looks I mean
he's he's scarring he [ __ ] he's visibly
shaking I'm really gonna be interested
to see this B's a lot of biggest
problems with Wolverine especially to
the movies is just how unstoppable he is
that was one of the really smart things
they did with the Wolverine which was to
knock his healing factor out of whack
now whether he's healing factors
completely God here or just not working
as well is it clear from this trailer
there were something said about that but
I'm going to come back to that stuff
we've got this wonderful desolate
isolated feel to it Patrick Stewart
looks great I mean he looks awful but
that feels right for Charles Xavier in
this there's no way he's living to the
end of this thing actually I'd say odds
are Wolverine isn't going to live to the
end of the season that's probably why
you said it in the futures like this is
the last story for you we get glimpses
of the girl they won't come farm that
it's x-23 but come on who else is if
they don't name it as X 23 she's
obviously some sort of composite
amalgamation of X 23 and like just a
generic sidekick carry me like le from
the last of us crossed with age 23 who
knows like I said I want
they're committing to it in a way though
I feel almost like this is kind of the
really easy way to go like when I said
you know the music track it seems like a
really obvious choices like yeah that
works but from what we knew about the
vibe of the thing that yeah I mean why
wouldn't you use that song so nothing
about this trail really particularly
blew me away or really caught my
attention but at the same time I saw
then going okay yeah I want to go see
this I want to see how this pans I want
to see if they can deliver on the
promise of this trailer makes the
promise of the trailers making isn't
necessarily something I am gung-ho about
but it's something I would like to see
well executed now I brought up some
things that have been said since the
trailer this is the advantage of the
fact that i did not get this video shot
as early as i had intended to because
the director james mango has come out
and said a few things about the trailer
since now as I said he won't confirm
that it's x-23 but something he did say
is that this is the days of future past
time I meeting when Wolverine sort of
jumps head at the very end of that and
he sees gene and Scott's alive and he
reconnects with Professor X this is that
time I move forward and that I kinda
hate cuz i really loved that ending at
the end of days of future past and it
was this wonderful happy ending just
close the book we can stop there for not
only Wolverine Hugh Jackman's Wolverine
but also for all these other characters
like see they're not really dead now
we're gonna jump ahead 20 years or
whatever it is oh no everybody is dead
well you just the game of the happy
ending I mean that's like what alien 3
did you're gonna undo everything that
was fought for in the previous film and
maybe in the movie itself it won't be
explicit that it's the same timeline I
can readjust my headcanon but it just
annoys me that that's the intent I would
prefer that they just told this story
and said look this is a timeline at this
one we have multiple possible timelines
in the x-men universe this is just one
of them I just wish they had not
explicitly connected it to that one
because as I said it
does that happy ending and I don't like
that but those are my overall thoughts
on it looks good not excited yet I don't
know I was so disappointed by how
mediocre apocalypse was is hard for me
to get excited for x-men right now even
though I really did like the Wolverine
quite a bit but in any case those are my
thoughts that's where i'm at right now
what were your thoughts on Logan and his
first trailer whatever they were drops
let me down on comments and let's talk
about it don't forget to Like subscribe
follow me on Twitter I council of geeks
check out the council of geeks podcast
available on iTunes and stitcher and
until next time this council is
adjourned